alright guys I just got my order today
for the twin master cubes which are the
black and white 4x4 cubes that you can
get from efforts.com I ordered them on
July 8th and it got here today on the
17th so it took roughly nine days with
processing and shipping to get it from
Hong Kong the twin pack was 34 dollars
each cube alone I believe is 18 so you
do save two dollars if you get the twin
pack I have heard that the clone
meffert's
or the Klepfer it's puzzle the 4x4 is
also very good if not better than the
meffert's however I decided to go with
the meffert's because they do have a
very good reputation and I've never
ordered a meffert's puzzle you might
also know that V cube the V cube company
is planning on making a V cube for which
I am also waiting on so that puzzle
should prove to be a competition for
these puzzles the 4x4 cubes that I have
now are the 4x4 Rubik's cube and also
the 4x4 East Chien cube of these two I'd
have to say that the 4x4 East Chien cube
is better it is pretty smooth and it
turns pretty well it's a it's a very
good speed cube I had to say as far as
the 4x4 Rubik's Cube it does get stuck a
lot so I was looking for a new 4x4 cube
and I heard that these were very good so
I was planning on doing an unboxing and
also a short review today on the
meffert's
twin master cubes alright I just wanted
to quickly comment on two things before
I get started with the unboxing and
review one of them is the white tiled
mf8 megaminx that I got from Rubik fans
the puzzle is $15 and I paid $8 for
shipping and handling because I got the
expedited international shipping so I
got it in around 8 to 9 days I'd have to
say that out of the box it was pretty
loose and it did spin nicely however the
pieces were popping a little bit so I
decided to take out the pieces and just
tighten the tension on each of the 12
sides and as of now it does spin very
nicely it can cut corners so I would
recommend this to beginners of the
megaminx or if you're just looking for a
good megaminx to buy I'd also like to
give a shout out to Kara whose birthday
is tomorrow July 18th on Saturday
and she does like dragonflies a lot so I
decided to make her the origami
dragonfly it took me about four hours to
actually figure out how to do it but I
hope she likes it so happy birthday Kara
alright so I just wanted to briefly show
you what's on the outside of the box
before I go on to cut it up there's just
these Hong Kong stamps on there with
birds my address and some stickers and
also the customs declaration that
basically has to be there if there's
products goods or even people coming
into the country alright so let's go on
to slice up the box there's the black
pepper it's master cube here's the white
cube nothing in there I don't know why
they bought that you include this and
that's just the invoice so that's what
was inside the box alright so let's take
off the bubble wrap
who the white one has some extra plastic
on it that this one didn't uh this one's
special and it's impossible to get off
out of the box it actually spins very
nicely what about the black one so they
both spin pretty nicely out of the box I
would like to try to solve them a little
bit and then I will give you guys a
little bit more information the methods
master Q but this is the white plastic
and this is the black plastic one they
both have tiles and as you can see the
white plastic one has black tiles and
the black plastic one has the white
tiles the rest of the Q basically has
the same color scheme as the Rubik's
brand so opposite of the whiter black
tiles you'll have the yellow opposite of
red you're going to have the orange and
opposite of green you're going to have
the blue each of the tiles are textured
meaning they have like a little bit of a
matte finish it gives it a nice grip and
on one corner on each side you will see
that there is a little logo that says
meffert's challenge as far as the
turning is concerned I could say that
both of these turn pretty much the same
I actually closed my eyes mixed up the
cubes in front of me and I wasn't able
to tell which one was which so I could
say that they both turned very well as
you could see out of the box even they
were spinning very nicely I solved them
a few times and I was very pleased with
them they don't catch nearly as much as
the Rubik's brand very rarely actually
do they do they get stuck so I am very
happy with the cubes I may
I may lubricate them in the future just
to make it spin a little bit nicer as
far as the size they are pretty much the
same as the Rubik's brand the tiles do
protrude a little bit making a little
bit larger and bulkier but I like the
tiles because as you can see here if I
hold it like this you can't really see
what colors on the other side of this
yellow edge piece here you can see it's
orange so I do like the fact that the
tiles protrude a little bit makes it a
little bit easier to see when your speed
solving so the mechanism of the
meffert's 4x4 cubes is very similar to
the mechanism of the rubik's 4x4 cube
they both have the ball core on the
inside which allows these pieces to turn
around the mefford's cube pretty much
has the same thing as you can see it has
that ball structure on the inside except
I believe the meffert's mechanism is
derived from an earlier mechanism which
is basically a little bit tighter and I
think it allows these layers to turn
very well and very smoothly so I would
definitely recommend the meffert's brand
over the Rubik's brand any time all
right guys so I hope you enjoyed the
review I do think that the meffert's
cubes are definitely worth it to to get
if you're looking for a good 4x4 puzzle
and I really can't say that the black
one is any better than the white one or
vice versa I think it just has to do
with your preference but I would
definitely recommend getting one of
these if you're looking for a good 4x4
puzzle so I hope you enjoyed the review
and thanks for watching